The Pilgrims founded Plymouth Plantation in
December 1620
and promptly commenced to get sick and die.
When the settlers finally stopped croaking,
they set about creating a Heaven on Earth.
A society without private property where all
worked for the common good.
Everything was shared, especially bitching
and moaning about working for the common good.
Let's let the colony's leader, William Bradford,
tell it:
And it wasn't just the menfolk who found the
situation unbearable.
With nobody working, everybody was suffering.
And in case you think nobody was working simply
because they couldn't understand
a damn thing Bradford was saying: chew on this.
In 1623 Bradford and the other leaders...
In no time at all:
America would never go hungry again.
So this week, before you drift into your annual
tryptophan induced coma,
don't forget to give thanks to the true patron of this holiday feast:
Property Rights.